elle
[Musique]
m
bonjour les amis bienvenue à manger
c'est voter on vient de débarquer ici à
bastia le grand port de haute corse moi
j'essaie beauté ce sont les sénateurs
qui nous emmène à la visite de leur
département et surtout des producteurs
et des éleveurs dans leurs coins de
france
et aujourd'hui on a rendez vous avec
poussant tout parigi le sénateur
nationaliste corse de notre sénat il
fait partie du groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires on va aller le
retrouver tout de suite en montagne
[Musique]
ap
là c'est vraiment le résumé de la corse
la mer avec les ferries dans le port de
bastia la montagne avec le maquis qui
nous entoure et les oliviers on va
quitter bastia nos pieds et honte on
monte vers corte le coeur de l'âme corse
un peu
[Musique]
sénateur paris dit bonjour
et bienvenue à santa luzia santa lucia
née mercurio c'est ça santa luzia des
mercurio qui est mon village natal mais
dénoncent un grave un puits et corte ça
se mérite la course ça c'est sûr on peut
peut-être se balader un petit peu dans
votre village bien sûr vous êtes
sénateur nationaliste corse et vous
appelez parigi c'est paris alors ces
blacks c'est pas la première fois qu'on
me l'a fait c'est là je me doute
d'ailleurs le slogan de campagne était
paris gym paris douala paris c'était le
bon temps moi je suis nationaliste
bon ça c'est sûr que nationaliste corse
un démocrate aussi et donc je prône
plutôt un statut d'autonomie pour la
course qu'une indépendance c'est à dire
ne pas se détacher de l'état français
mais en revanche avoir les pleins
pouvoirs chez où exactement pouvoir
exercer un certain nombre de compétences
sans être obligé chaque fois de
téléphoner à paris alors sénateur non
seulement vous êtes nationalistes
démocrates mais vous êtes aussi un
écologiste j'ai appris ça puisque vous
faites partie d'un groupe au sénat qui
prône l'écologie mais c'est presque
naturel pour les corps sain j'ai
l'impression pour les nationalistes
corses d'écologie fait partie des
valeurs qui n'ont jamais été à côté de
nos revendications il ne pleut plus
depuis maintenant ici voix et même dans
des villages à une altitude comme celle
de santa logis on commence à voir des
craintes un manque d'eau et c'est donc
l'écologie fait partie des soucis
permanent aujourd'hui en politique alors
où que l'on regarde ici c'est la
montagne ce putt facile pour le cadastre
cook avait été maire plus de 20 ans ici
comme d'autres on est on est habitué à
la géographie de la corse et une
géographie très escarpée comme le son si
des corses
[Musique]
on va visiter n'est lié au buste un
lazarini way qui sont chevrier dans
cette belle région rennaise qui est un
haut lieu du fromage de chèvre ses rares
en corse ayant encore quelques-uns qui
sont des résistants donc ils vont nous
montrer leur travail et la confection du
groupe
c'est votre troupeau qu'on voit passer
en balancer les chefs qui sortent là et
il y en a beaucoup encore forme en
trouve encore beaucoup moins en moins
pourquoi est ce qu'on en fait on prend
d'autres races venus d'ailleurs sont
moins productifs que les autres si tu es
moche beaucoup et là elles vont aller
loin dans la sueur la fête est prévue en
décembre et vous monter jusqu'en haut
des crêtes j'ai des chefs sauvage
j'avais un voit avec les semaines et les
poitevines ce sénateur la montagne en
haute corse c'est un biotope est un
territoire très particulier où le
pastoralisme a toute sa place comment
est ce que le politique peut aider c'est
beaucoup l'europe qui s'occupe de
l'agriculture et ce niveau là il ya des
choses qui doivent être changées tous
qu'ils aient voté souvent au niveau de
l'europe thèse sur le fait que beaucoup
de berger baisse les bras beaucoup de
jeunes ne s'installe pas et ces produits
qui ont une grande valeur ajoutée mais
qui n'entrant pas dans les normes et ne
peuvent pas bénéficier dao paie un autre
notre travail de parlementaires c'est de
faire que les choses changent à ce
niveau là ici on est en pleine montagne
entouré de maquis et c'est vraiment le
paradis pour la chèvre de dire que le
groupe est aujourd'hui le caviar de la
course 1 il faut se connaître
aujourd'hui
vous êtes en train de remuer votre lait
dans un vieux chaudrons en cuivre le
bronze je laissais dans l'état de leurs
griffes parce que ses traditionnels et
effectivement le sait mieux pour le
compte de la fée c'est peut-être les
parfums de l'enfance qui remonte c'est
des parfums d'enfance c'est de le goûter
17 pas tout le monde le fait lorsqu'il
sort chaud à quelle température ça sort
des lilas le brunch saf l'oculaire 85°
n'a donc je suis
chaud comme ça voilà mais vous faites
attention du coup c'est très chaud allez
courage ce sénateur allez-y vous avez
l'habitude sa trame comme ça c'est
certain voilà il va trembler le
continent c'est le sage il y fit un peu
comme un fou voilà c'est ça ça plus de
texture dans ce nombre
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est bon
je comprends qu'ils payent le goûter
chaud pour vraiment avoir le naissance
du brocciu fermiers les lys à ce moment
où ça
alors ça cela je vous les ai fait exprès
on va aller déguster ce soir
on se sent on va pour les ranger il vous
les ont écoutés changer de roue
ses chances se vendre des producteurs
fermiers en panne ce qui se trouve à
corte qui existe depuis sept ans où on
vend exclusivement que la production
fermière les gens doivent être
responsables de ce qu'ils achètent et
d'arrêter de subir la grande
distribution qui nous fait croire parce
qu'elle est très forte en communication
qu'est ce qu'on mange ce qu'on achète
c'est bien qu'il ya toujours un
producteur derrière il faut aller voir
les producteurs on peut plus ne plus
avoir conscience de son mais dans notre
assiette ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est
qu'il ya une chance inouïe encore dans
l'esprit des français quand on dit
produits corses dans des produits de
qualité lorsqu'on me dit on voit que ça
coule de source comme ça mais derrière
la qualité il ya de plus en plus des
personnes qui se battent tous les jours
parce que la corse n'est pas exempte de
personnes qu'il faudrait faire aussi un
peu tout et n'importe quoi il faut dire
les choses comme elles sont c'est que
c'est pas parce que ces corps c'est
forcément bien parce qu'on est arrivé
maintenant à saturation de notre système
c'est à dire avec des milliers de
touristes et donc on a besoin de vente
du produit corse mais renseignez vous
sur ce que vous achetez ces produits-là
la basicité traditionnel le fromage la
charcuterie et ils ont quand même
galvaudé maintenant je sais ce que je
donne à manger à mes chefs donc du coup
ce qu'il ya dans mon lait mais moi je
suis convaincu de plus en plus qui a que
le produit fermier qui peut garantir
cette qualité quoi j'y retourne
m'excuser parce que moi je n'ai pas eu
une enfance dans le brocciu donc j'ai du
temps à rattraper
bon faudrait peut-être qu'on continue
nos visites mais voilà exactement
[Musique]
mon cher vincent tu vois ici on est dans
le paradis du produit corse de qualité
c'est le magasin de producteurs tel
qu'on le rêve c'est à dire pas
d'intermédiaires circuits courts on a
avec un délit et stéphane bien sûr
producteurs faut le dire quand même de
beaucoup nous strahl
c'est ce port noir ce port ce port corse
quoi toutes les charcuteries qu sur la
sont les vôtres
il ya un collectif en fait d'éleveurs de
porcs coincé butin ces deux petites
exploitations plutôt qu'une grande donc
il ya plusieurs petites exploitations
ont vachement à chaque fois leur
rencontre des producteurs c'est que du
magasin enfin du magasin du point de
vente collectif et venir et notamment
les fromages puisqu'on était tout à
l'heure avec nelly vous nous avez suivi
mais
vous êtes venu faire une petite
livraison du coup vous fait goûter ici
au magasin parfois alors ça c'est un
lounge où c'est à dire c'est le filet de
porc il est couvert comme on dit un chez
moi il est bien couvert j'ai très grave
mais si tu combats faut que je montre
qu'on se rende bien compte on dirait un
paysage on à la montagne et rouge là au
soleil couchant et au dessus un ciel un
peu voilé quelle merveille quand on ose
laissé beaucoup de gras comme ça sur une
pièce c'est qu'on est sûr qu'on a de la
qualité parce que lorsqu'on en reste
très peu et le grave souvent neuvien
rance hélas la charcuterie n'est plus
bonne donc c'est parce qu'on a un braque
et bien blanc comme ça absolument on est
sur des morceaux qui sont excellents sur
le plan de la structure magasins comme
celui-là ça fonctionne comment on fait
du statut associatif on a créé une
association en 2015 donc il ya sept ans
maintenant sept producteurs se sont
regroupés au départ pour la vente de nos
produits locaux on avait envie de casser
un peu les connais pas de répondre pour
une demande touristique et et c'est pas
aux producteurs de s'adapter à la
clientèle mais c'est la clientèle de
venir goûter les locaux quand c'est la
saison le consommateur s'y retrouve
parce qu a pas d'intermédiaire donc les
prix sont piégeuses et puis surtout on
discute pour qu'un prix c'est à dire que
c'est l'agriculteur qui bénéficient de
revenus on se rend compte en fait au
bout de sept ans maintenant dès qu'on a
une action si sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire on a réussi à créer de
l'emploi on valorise les déchets on est
en fait une se trouve en lien avec
toutes les problématiques qu'ils
apparaissent sur la corse on y répond et
en fait on se rend compte qu un niveau
citoyens à un niveau de production on
peut changer aussi les choses bah oui
faire que c'est aussi une alimentation
politique dans le sens bien
effectivement dans ce discours un
challenge gagner mais autour d'un état
d'esprit et une volonté commune à la
fois du travail mais de la passion aussi
de ce qu'on fait on pourrait dire
mandjra et roda
[Musique]
je vois qu'on est attendu
c'est parce qu'on transporte le déjeuner
salut les cocos
les cocons les cochons bien sûr en fait
c'est un peu comme le petit déjeuner le
les complexes quoi
alors vous faites tout de a à z stéphane
hains ici c'est à dire naisseur éleveurs
engraisseurs transformateurs rien ne
vous échappe dans le travail du cochon
il ya le seul maillon qui nous échappe
c'est celui de l'abattage il ya mille
manières d'abattre les cochons et de
délais j'ai découpé et malheureusement
c'est une perte de savoir faire et ce
maillon qui nous échappe en plus on
passe par un modèle industriel
puisque c'est d'abattage à la chaîne
dans les abats oui y'a pas d'abattoirs
plus respectueux en fête du travail de
l'éleveur traditionnel on va dire c'est
sûr que les paysans quand y tuer le
cochon ça leur coûtait rien maintenant
ça coûte l'abattage et puis ça coûte la
bétaillère pour les emmener et puis pour
acheter une remorque qui soient aux
normes et il faut passer le permis on
rentre dans une spirale où on prend
dépensons défense ont dépensé après
malheureusement ça se répercute sur le
prix d'achat cutri la filière porcine ne
va pas super bien il ya la tentation
d'avoir une certaine taille critique
pour gagner sa vie est ce qu'on peut
vivre décemment d'une petite
exploitation de port non se ressent pas
d'une filière on se sent la filière
paysage mais je me sens beaucoup plus
proche de nelly que d'un éleveur breton
qui a 500 plus dans un bâtiment c'est
pour ça que nous on n'a que des ports
corses et que l'on veut défendre les
valeurs de la charcuterie traditionnelle
et c'est important de gagner sa vie en
travaillant mais c'est pas le côté
économique qui nous guide dans notre foi
vous êtes en train de me dire que vous
gagneriez beaucoup plus d'argent à faire
beaucoup moins bien
ça il faut qu'on en ait conscience dans
le bloc dans le port français la
charcuterie corse
malheureusement c'est à 90% des porcs
blancs qui viennent du continent qui
vient de se faire crucifier ici c'est
scandaleux
alors c'est scandaleux à moment donné il
ya une demande donc il est bien on a
bien du bébé le juge est de répondre
maintenant vous a bien qu'on peut d'état
d'esprit état d'esprit c'est de tendre
vers une production comme celle là moi
je veux faire la différence entre de la
charcuterie de porc corse et la
charcuterie corse
comment je fais celui qui va venir en
vacances qui va venir avec un peu
structuré dire là je vais trouver de la
bonne charcuterie de la vraie c'est pas
possible ce qu'il faut c'est que c'est
qui c'est qui discute avec les gens
c'est qu'ils se rencontrent des
personnes et en discutant se faire
conseiller sera fait rencontrer des
éleveurs etc etc et consommer comme ça
quand on nous dit j'ai retrouvé le goût
de la charité de mon grand père ou de ma
tente à lire ça ça c'est la plus belle
des récompenses
[Musique]
alors où est ce qu'on est ici monsieur
le sénateur alors on est à l'école
d'aléria et on va visiter aujourd'hui sa
cantine et son chef cuisinier stéphane
qui va nous présenter un plat
traditionnel
c'est une cuisine qui travaille avec 100
% de produits locaux oui et en plus en
circuits courts c'est à dire que entre
le produit et l'école bas il n'ya qu'un
pas ou quand ils ont la chance chez les
élèves on est à pied d'oeuvre l'âge
bonjour on ce tchèque ok c'est une
habitude dans les habitudes qu'est ce
que je vois des frais ce corse les 13
corse tout écosse le cul ou écorces la
fraise et corse et l'orangé cause des
dons vos élèves ou les soigner un
tassement les premières fraises c'est
presque du luc cintrat oui mais c'est
tout ce qu'il faut a alors c'est
intéressant parce que sur le plan de la
saison agrumes hiver fraises printemps
là on est à la croisée saaq racing
vraiment la période quoi va peut-être
passer en cuisine puisque on y va ça me
donne change ça sent très bon
ça ce sont les produits du menu vous
voulez je vous montrerai a fait a sauté
de veau corse aussi d'accord c'est ça
c'est tous les agréments que je mets le
manceau alors stéphane monsieur le
sénateur à l'instant disaient tous les
produits de cette cantine son corps sont
locaux c'est le vous aussi leveaux
écosse il vient d'où il vient km c'est
un producteur jacques marianne c'est
100% de ses moyens australie ce nouveau
l'australie à melbourne australie on a
vu tout à l'heure le cochon mistral
c'est un voyage de deux ou trois
kilomètres comme pour les fruits
sont cueillis sur l'arbre et amener
directement ici est-ce que je peux
goûter la science du sol
à
ses supérieurs ah ouais très très bonne
vraiment écoutez si je le faisais à la
maison je pense que ça sera moins bien à
ces gens si
stéphane est-ce que c'est facile
l'approvisionnement autour de vous pour
pour la quantité que vous servez ici oui
ça va priorité au local je verrai si je
préférais un produit local de saison
plutôt qu'un produit bio qui viendrait
de bastia ou parce que pour vous déjà
bastia c'est l'étranger quoi à
l'étranger mais préfère faire travailler
mes potes circuits courts ouais en
priorité à vue il ya toujours du bureau
ni à 40 % de bio par semaine un tour
mais c'est vraiment priorité c'est le
circuit court et le local est ce que
c'est pas ça l'esprit qui prédomine ici
un ce qu'on voit depuis ce matin au fond
que rien ne remplace le lien avec le
producteur l'éleveur parce qu'on sait
comment il travaille si on si on le
connaît en fait on va pas chercher des
bonnes choses très loin on les a autour
de nous et à partir de ce qu'on a autour
de l'eau dont on compose comme on le
voit ici faire son marché autour de chez
soi ça a un prix et je suppose pour une
restauration scolaire comme celle là
aussi surtout que l'étiquette à 3,070
3,070 c'est ce que ça coûte à chaque
élève à chacun et chaque déjeuner c'est
grâce à l'amérique on arrive justement à
faire des 1000 comme ça sur la mairie on
n'y arriverait pas possible le politique
parce qu'il est dans une démarche qui
doit s'impliquer même si ça coûte à la
collectivité mais où on a un cuisinier
qui est fier où on a un personnel qui
travaille volontiers parce que parce
qu'il touche au produit parce qu'ils
goûtent aux produits est automatiquement
le pôle le politique est là pour
accompagner tout ça
je vais faire c'est que j'ai rallumé le
feu en dessous parce que là c'était un
peu juste en température et comme
l'heure du déjeuner approche si c'est
parti ils ont de la chance les gars le
soir ici que vous le dira pas partout
pareil
[Musique]
les agrumes c'est comme nan pas
important de la culture corse ah c'est
pour ça que je vous ai amené ici
monsieur le sénateur je voulais vous
faire rencontrer un agrumiculteurs
gendrey cardoze et on est en fin de
saison dépôt vélo ils sont magnifiques
cpo mélo corse on les connaît pas trouve
d'ailleurs sur le continent ce cardozo
bonjour les manants jus ça on le juge a
tranché en train de vérifier dans la
mâture immaturité aujourd'hui dans le
populo qui est le deuxième plus gros
agrumes deuxième production d'agrumes
construit d un lac léman a créé ont-ils
fait trentaine de 38 tonnes à peu près
qui nous permet de diversifier d'être
toujours présent sur les marchés
après l'affairé en écrivant tin qui fut
dur elle que deux mois et demi là on
fait déjà on peut déjà voir la pousse
qui ce qui se prépare avec la fleur ou
pas oui si la relance reste peu il peut
donner un signal à ses bourgeons de ne
pas faire de fruits pour l'un prochaine
si au moment destin duction flora qui en
janvier février les conditions ne sont
pas favorables pour lui et que son état
physique ou n'est pas bon il referme
tout qu'est-ce qui fait il donne il
donne l'ordre à ses bourgeons qui vont
produire l'année prochaine jésus pas en
forme je fais pas de fleurs pas de
fruits donc je fais des feuilles pour la
synthèse quoi la photosynthèse et
peinture c'est très simple dites moi
monsieur le sénateur on se rend compte
qu'il ya la chance d'avoir la montagne
donc toujours avoir eu des rivières des
torrents et de l'eau qui descendait da
pont des neiges il ya de moins en moins
de neige donc moins en moins d'eau dans
les rivières ça devient un problème
quand on voit le niveau des rivières
avec aucun à l'enneigement sur les
montagnes on se demande comment on va
faire pour fournir de l'eau bien sûr à
l'agriculture c'est important mais même
tout simplement trop humain corps humain
on a installé des sons un peu partout
c'est qu'on sait précisément ce qu'il ya
où il ya besoin voilà sauf que là on
s'aperçoit qu'en faisant le tour de nos
sondes parce que c'est constamment en
étant il faudrait rosé à cette époque la
moitié aurait alors que c'est
normalement la période où il pleut
aujourd'hui quand on regarde le sondé
nous disent alerte c'est à dire que les
racines le sol est tellement sec qu'elle
ne sont plus au contact du substrat mais
quand c'est sec on est croche pied ça
peut avoir des conséquences assez graves
moi j'ai une demande et c'est possible
mais j'aimerais bien voir vos cédera
ilaina reste quelques-uns on va le voir
c'est quelque chose qui facilite en plus
à des gestions il faut le couper en
lamelles comme une hostie on peut goûter
merci donc c'est ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'albédo c'est à dire le east 1
leblanc cette école de vélo comme dans
les cédera ya très peu de pub pc 80%
d'albédo c'est qu'on a évidemment toute
l'huile essentielle du cédrat oui
franchement mais on a aussi un côté
poivré et un côté presque curie
à l'organiser agrumes ça doivent ça doit
être super sur un poisson c'est sûr
excusez moi mais moi ça me donne soif je
crois que vous connaissez quelqu'un qui
a un domaine viticole une femme qui
cultive la vigne josé vannuchi
[Musique]
alors pour nous on passe des clémentines
raisins on arrive dans le vignoble qui
couvre une grande partie de cette côte
orientale de la corse et qui est quand
même filière qui est très bien développé
bonjour c'est d'aimer nos jours merci
salud one by two many si vous venez ici
oui je suis en train de regarder les
marques de du réchauffement climatique
là on vient d'attaquer une année très
sèche oui comme ans et déjà sept là on
voit que on voit que là on est déjà on
est déjà sec là le bien-être végétales
et bien il est il est mise à mal par le
réchauffement climatique
moi je suis ici à mon petit niveau en
train de protéger un patrimoine mondial
c'est à dire que les cépages corse
genovese bianco gentiletti menez equal
tatchou binta diouf tous ces noms là qui
ont été éradiqués parce qu'il ya eu une
phase de l'histoire ces cépages
allogènes qui sont arrivés et on a perdu
la mémoire en corse parce qu'on est de
tradition orale la langue les cépages
tout ça pour moi c'est les mêmes combats
pour luz en tout on se dit que là c'est
l'illustration même que nationalismes
des régionalismes en corse se
superposent
en fait j'ai toujours dit c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire comprendre souvent au
sénat de dire il faut revenir à fait
l'idée de régionalisme en corse on dit
pas je suis chez moi quand on parle de
terre en corse on dit stone entamait ce
qui veut dire je suis sur moi
bon je voudrais pas paraître désagréable
jose mais je crois que je commence à
ressentir les effets de la sécheresse
bien volontiers imedi et aller allons-y
[Musique]
dans votre cuvier rock'n'roll pop
culture ça se mélange et j'aime le rock
et je suis profondément corse oui parce
que c'est ce qu'on veut aujourd'hui
c'est qu'un vin raconte l'histoire de là
où il est et de celui ou celle qui le
fait tout cas c'est mon objectif et
j'espère petit à petit et modestement il
parvenir toujours plus chaque année et
après chaque millésime josé partout en
corse malgré la demande que de plus en
plus forte notamment due au tourisme
vous essayez de maintenir les prix les
plus justes les plus serré possible moi
personnellement mon choix c'est de
maintenir les prix pour que les gens qui
vivent autour de moi qui font partie de
mon territoire et de mon terroir puisse
offrir mes bouteilles un cousin moi pas
loin hébergés quand ils organisent la
tombe de ses brebis on appelle ça
attendez encore il vient il prend du vin
chez moi parce que je suis aussi sa
cousine et que imaginer le vin serait
cinq fois plus cher il le prendrait de
la même manière et nous allons les râles
et puis l'aurait pas les moyens par
aller mais je pense que c'est une à une
responsabilité serein sur les prix aussi
on ne peut pas bloquer l'accès de ses
produits aux personnes qui vivent auprès
de vous en fait ce qu'on a bien vu des
producteurs qui font des choses de
qualité mais qui ont quand même une
attention particulière sur le prix et
donc qu'ils ne sont pas là pour
assassiner les consommateurs mais moi
j'adore un syndicat dont le slogan est
pro 2 gp quand pas produire pour vivre
donc moi je produis pour vivre et pas
pour fait qu les
tout simplement
[Musique]
c'est à paris dit nous sommes revenus
gérés sur les lieux du crime ce magasin
de producteurs le soir ça fait aussi un
peu bistrot taverne ml nous a prévu ce
fameux brocciu je vous sais 7 mais bien
sur moi dans ma région on ne mangeait
avec un peu de sucre et surtout on
n'oublie pas d'y mettre une goutte d'eau
de vie une goutte à goutte d'accord ces
de vie c'est ça notre vie oui
l'hôtel de raisin bien sûr je regarde
votre goûter puis je m'adapte un ouais
ok alors sénateur moi je me pose quand
même des questions au bout de sept
journées et qui était riche où j'ai vu
vraiment cette ferveur cette envie décor
de votre département de haute-corse qui
ont envie de bien faire si demain vous
étiez propulsé à la tête de l'état voilà
comme napoléon alors peut-être pas
empereur mais au moins un premier consul
ou l'équivalent président de la
république quelles mesures prendre il
vous tout de suite et pour la corse et
pour la france
alors je vous dire s'ils me ce qui me
tient à coeur voilà une des premières
mesures que je prendrais s'étonnerait
beaucoup plus d'indépendance aux régions
je me battrai pour que les langues
régionales soit enseignée dans les
écoles on travaillerait sur les
débouchés que peu à voir l'agriculture
mais je suis pour que les territoires
plus avoir une certaine autosuffisance
par l'agriculture pour pouvoir parer un
certain nombre de problématiques qui se
posent
[Musique]
vous savez que les français aiment la
corse est ce que vous pensez qu'ils
l'aiment mal ou pour les mauvaises
raisons j'ai traversé la france je les
visite est de long en large il ya des
personnes comme nous en france qui
défendent leur culture leur langue etc
moi je crois que c'est l'état qui n'a
pas compris la grosse nous sommes nous
sommes une colonie la corse était une
nation avec avec son administration avec
avec son armée avec sa monnaie etc elle
a été conquise pour autant vous êtes
nationaliste n'est pas indépendantiste
voulait pas fait ce choix ça veut dire
qu'il ya encore de l'espoir d'une
compatibilité entre la france et la
corse on est aujourd'hui en europe je
crois que les nations ont perdu un peu
de leur pouvoir je suis un européen
convaincu je suis aussi réaliste on a
toujours ce poids d'étatiques ce poids
préfectoral sur les sur les décisions et
c'est pas cela comme inspire aujourd'hui
en course de super autre chose alors on
lève mon verre à quoi à l'europe des
régions à l'europe des régions à l'appel
en europe parce que la peine est très
importante
[Musique]
m
et non
oh